Robert Pattinson thought the story was
ridiculous from the start like what am I
doing with this right kid I'm 108 years
old he complained that Harvey gets to
any vampire stuff and by that he meant I
mean uh and I need to kill anyone after
talking to Stephanie Meyer Robert
thought that she was in love with her
own fictional creation it's like this
woman is mad he didn't think all too
highly of Twilight fans either calling
them people who sit in front of their
computers and comment on anything to do
with Twilight at least Robert thought of
the fans when he was asked if the end of
Twilight was bittersweet after them it
could have been worse Robert at least
she didn't have Taylor Lautner's
experience with fans Roberts said that
if he wasn't in the movies he would just
mindlessly hate Twilight Rob also
complained that his contacts were so
uncomfortable my entire performance is
based on have extreme discomfort having
contact lens in your eyes